so last time on true fear I talked about
the LA sleepwalker
if you haven't seen that video click
here and you can go check it out so I
never saw the El a sleepwalker again but
I did make a habit of going out there to
check to see if it was a habit that he
was doing it every night or something he
wasn't but what I did notice is some
other very strange things around my
apartment complex now this was not a
nice apartment by any standards but it
was student housing and it was close to
school I wish I had never stayed there
but there's nothing I do about it now so
anyways there's all these closets
scattered around the apartment complex
and usually they're just closed and
locked
but when I got back one night from going
to check for the sleepwalker I noticed
that one of them was open and none of
them have ever been opened before so me
and my roommates go to investigate and
we just find all of this crazy stuff
inside of the closet lawn chairs cones a
shovel just all of these random objects
that anyone who lives in an apartment
would never really need I don't remember
all of the exact items though and the
thing that was really weird about this
is that none of our resident keys gave
access to any of the closets so if these
closets weren't for residents storage
then who were they for so we decided to
do a little investigating and check out
all the doors in the apartment complex
that didn't lead to other people's units
most of the closets were either locked
or empty but we did discover two new
doors that we could access one was at
the end of our hallway which you can
actually see here in dead air and the
other one was on the hallway opposite of
ours and they both led to these secret
stairways which probably weren't a
secret to the stoners of that apartment
building because they both smelled like
weed the stairway closest to us had a
doorway leading out to the side alley
well the one on the other side did not
we always thought that the main
staircase which you can see right here
in acrimonious was the only way to get
up or down in the building because
whatever labels that had been on these
stairwells to tell you that they were
stairs had been torn off but the most
important part was at the top of each
stair well there were two doors one
leading back to the resident hallways
and one leading to we don't know what so
we wanted to figure out what these other
doors led to at the top of the staircase
closest to us the door was locked but on
the other side it was open
behind the door there's this tiny closet
and in the back of the closet there's
this metal hatch about two feet by two
feet so we open the hatch and it leads
to the chute we look down in the chute
and there's the secret room underneath
and we had no idea how to access this
room from the rest of the building and
we had no idea that it existed before so
I poked my head down there and it was
pitch black but with the help of a phone
light we were able to see a few things
there were some boxes some canned food
and a sleeping bag so I immediately
pulled my light out of there because
what's going through my head is there's
someone living down there and if they
see the light they're probably gonna
walk underneath and look back at us and
if something like that did happen I
imagine the person would probably be
enraged that we found out that they were
living down there because let's face it
the management at that building
however lazy they may be probably
wouldn't be too happy if there was
someone secretly living inside and they
would be likely to investigate actually
on second thought that management
literally didn't care about us at all
but that would be considered trespassing
if somebody was down there so if
somebody found out they could
potentially get the police involved
think about if you were living down
there and somebody found out about you
that's potentially threatening like your
entire existence your entire way of
living you would probably want to do
something about it and I know that
sounds kind of overdramatic but you have
to keep in mind that these people on the
streets in LA are there for a reason
it's a sad reality but you see a lot of
people who are mentally ill or at least
like mentally unstable so honestly the
idea of somebody seeing us and coming
after us was not entirely out of the
question
especially considering the fact that we
have nowhere to hide because they know
that we live in those apartments and
they could easily follow us back or lurk
by the entrance until we go in or out
and I know this whole thing might sound
a little over-the-top considering we had
no actual evidence that anyone was
living down there just a top-down view
of some canned food in a sleeping bag
but you have to remember that I have a
very dark imagination and there was
enough evidence to at least confirm that
there was something going on so we went
back to our apartment and started
discussing what we had seen and thus the
idea of the hobo king was born or at
least it started as just an idea
being creative people we came up with
this whole scenario in character
revolving around the hobo king in our
story
the hobo king is actually a very smart
man who figured out how to live his life
safely and efficiently without needing
to get a job and has since reached out
to other homeless people in the area to
help give them a shelter overnight
so he dubbed himself that hobo King and
started donning tattered robes made up
of rags and one of those Burger King
birthday crowns that he found in the
dumpster
he's a very egotistical character so
over time he amassed all these followers
and he gave them a place to stay in
exchange for collecting taxes from the
people off the streets so if you're
homeless and you want to stay in the
hobo king's castle if you will you could
do so by giving him 20% of the earnings
that you made begging by the freeway
ramp so that's the extent of what we
made up the rest of this is all real
I'll still be referring to the homeless
person as the hobo king for the rest of
the story then so from that point
forward we started checking up in the
closets and monitoring what was going on
in the property after the staff left
every night and what we found was that
while all the closets are usually locked
every now and then a random one of them
would be left open and we would just
find more weird things inside with that
one door at the end of the staircase
that led to the chute was always open we
think that somebody left it open a while
ago one of the staff members and perhaps
forgot about it and it's just been left
open ever since but the question still
remained how was the hobo king getting
access to this supposedly gated property
who is the one getting inside and
granting access to all of these doors
and closets to answer that we looked at
the three types of people who have
access to the property the residents the
managers and the maintenance guy anyone
else who came onto the property like
pest control for example was an
independent worker and didn't have
access to anything as I mentioned
earlier as residents we didn't have
access to any of those doors because
none of our keys worked on them so that
just left the manager and the
maintenance guy both of them were
absolutely awful the manager would
really only stop in for about an hour
every day to meet with potential leases
and then leave right after that we know
this because whenever we had a problem
and we tried to get ahold of the manager
it was impossible and we would end up
just having to wait around all day by
the managers office that just leaves us
with the maintenance guy who was
abhorrent ly lazy whenever we had an
issue he would just show up like a week
later with one of his friends yes he
would just bring some of his friends to
work with him sometime
we would tell him about the problem we
were having he would be like oh ok I'll
be right back and then he would leave
and never come back
but we did notice that he would spend a
lot of time behind closed doors in his
office talking to one of his friends
that he had brought to work which led me
to this theory one of the maintenance
guys friends is the hobo King the
maintenance guy feels bad for him and
leaves him open a closet or room to stay
in each night after the hobo King gains
some followers he convinces the
maintenance guy to let a few of them
stay as well over time it leads to an
infestation this theory is backed up
because during the day when the
maintenance guy was in is when all the
locks would get changed
which was also when we were away at
class we would also see the maintenance
guy roaming around with a huge keyring
with dozens and dozens of keys and
finally the maintenance guy was always
in his office but he was never actually
out maintaining or fixing anything
we continued to keep tabs and all the
activity that was taking place around
the apartment complex but what we really
wanted to know is how to access that
secret room with the exception of
opening the hatch and thrown a rope and
climbing down and then being stuck down
there with a potentially crazy homeless
person and no exit we assumed that the
chute and another chute that we assumed
also exists on the stairwell by our side
we're both garbage chutes at one time
that they just got too lazy to keep
taking to the street and then move the
dumpsters to the street for us to take
our garbage out to if that's true then
there had to be an entrance somewhere
most likely and the two alleyways on
either side of the building first we
checked the alleyway on our side we
didn't find a secret door on our side
but we did find like this all these
scuba books and scuba equipment that had
just been scattered out in the alley for
some reason I really don't know what to
make of that that doesn't even have to
do with the story at all but I just
thought I'd throw that in there we had
to hop a fence to access the alleyway on
the other side a fence that seemed to be
guarding nothing but an empty alleyway
until we found a door on the side of the
building that lined up with the exact
location where the secret room should be
we were actually pretty nervous to go
inside because what if there was a
homeless person living in there right
now
but we wanted answers so we decided to
just quietly go inside and see if there
was anything going on in there so I go
down the alleyway to open the door
my roommates get ready to run if need be
I turn the handle and the door's locked
but here's the thing we don't know if
it's locked from the inside or the
outside so just to play it safe we book
it all the way back to the other side
all the way back until we're safe inside
of our apartment so for a while we're
just sitting there discussing it and
kind of building on the lore of the hobo
king so in the apartment we have this
big rear projection TV and while we were
talking I kept looking over at the
window because I felt like I saw
something moving and I should add that
the window leads to the alleyway on our
side and then at one point I thought I
saw something on the TV but the TV was
off this was a reflection and in the
reflection I see the outline of a man's
head and staring through the window I
look over to the window and the man's
gone I look back to the TV to see if it
was maybe something else and whatever it
was was gone
all I can see in the reflection is the
empty window now I'm not gonna
immediately cry hobo King because we did
make that character up but I don't think
it's out of the question to suggest that
there may have been someone living in
the building or maybe not I mean we had
a neighbor who lived next to us who had
somebody break in through his window so
it really could have been anybody but
there is one more chapter to this story
we didn't end up staying at the
apartment complex much longer than that
and no we did not leave because of the
hobo King but basically what happened is
there is this leak in our ceiling and
the maintenance guy was too lazy to fix
it and it turned into a hole in the
ceiling and once the hole formed in the
ceiling we got bedbugs and it was just
this whole huge disaster the bedbugs
were a fate far worse than any hobo King
are really far worse than anything at
all it was an awful experience but
that's a whole nother story but anyways
we were kind of getting over the whole
hobo king thing because we hadn't seen
anything in a while but before we left
we were walking around and we noticed
that there was one more closet door that
had been left open and it wasn't one
that we had previously seen open at any
time before so we opened it there was
some electrical panels wires and
switches
plant but on the floor there was a
blanket and pillow and it wasn't like
they were folded up and stored in the
corner they were laid out like an actual
bed but the craziest part of any of this
was in the closet
there was a bunch of graffiti on the
walls and they were mostly just like
so-and-so was here and pictures of
penises and what-have-you
but there is this one little bit of text
that completely blew my mind
it said King so as we were filming this
my buddy West Dakota who is helping me
film these videos actually mentioned
that he has a little bit more
information that I wasn't even aware of
so I'm gonna hand it over to him so this
apartment complex ended the contract
with our school due to a whole slew of
issues but a couple months before that
contract ended hanging up around the
complex were signs telling the residents
to make sure that the gates were closed
because there were a bunch of homeless
people getting into the complex and
sleeping in the closets you've been told
about so that just confirms the story a
little bit more about how there were
homeless people staying in this
apartment complex and I didn't even know
that going into this I just asked Dakota
to come to help me make a video he
didn't know that I was recording this at
all and he just happened to stumble upon
that little bit of information this was
the last of what I have to tell about
the hobo King I was actually working on
a found footage webseries for a while
based on our apartment complex and our
idea of what the hobo King might be it
included characters that represented
each of us as well as some new made-up
characters sadly I never got to shoot it
before the bed bugs forced us out of
that place and the script really did
rely on the geographical layout of that
complex however after the bed bugs we
found ourselves hopping around from
hotel to hotel for a while so on the
next episode of true fear I'll be
telling you guys about the crazy woman
in one of the rooms leave your own
theories about the hobo king in the
comments if we get 200 likes on this
video I will read you guys the script
for my found-footage web series about
the hobo king either here or on my other
series all dainty creepypasta so make
sure to share this video get it out
there get it some likes and as always
don't forget to subscribe and I will see
you in the next video
assuming we both
five